yeah what you guys wanting a rap that
the Hound of the Baskervilles that's
great yeah that's a good suggestion cool
the Hound of the Baskervilles make noise
if you actually read the story okay cool
nice twelve people will enjoy that
segment of the rap let's come to the
kind of this half of the room near the
front if you're kind of in the middle to
the front what to unwrap that well
because I've said what was the last word
you said serfdom okay cool
do you guys understand what the feudal
system is if you don't that's gonna be
more obscure than Hound of the
Baskervilles don't worry I will explain
it in the ramp so far the Hound of the
Baskervilles 15th century serfdom back
at the riches because we're in her mo
see you're alike yeah we know what serf
it is Chris know is different it's a
totally different thing
spell sei right back in the room what
you Iraq that Anglo Irish relations that
sounded like you were outside the venue
it just sounds like an Irishman was just
walking past us I was like that sounds
like an English person inside how about
Anglo Irish relations you prick and then
they just walk off down the road cool
Anglo Irish relations let's get to more
suggestions one from this kind of
segment of this side boring suggesting
I'm afraid we've set the bar really high
with those three you see so I'm not
going any lower than that
octogenarian strippers that is a great
suggestion thank you
so Hound of the Baskervilles 15th
century serfdom anglo-irish relations
and optogenetic strippers guys over here
you have the final suggestion it needs
to be good to compete with all those
what's it gonna be no what was that
Lebanon okay you from Lebanon yeah cool
it's gonna say no one's thinking of
Lebanon really these days are they
that's a great suggestion I really feel
that maybe four-fifths of these
suggestions will go over many of your
heads I think really octogenarian
strippers is gonna be the high point
you're like yeah we know what that is I
mean we don't really know what the word
octogenarian means but we know our
stripper is so to remind you all the
Hound of the Baskervilles 15th century
serfdom anglo-irish relations
auctioneering strippers and Lebanon this
then lovely people at the comedy magic
club a little Christmas treat for you a
little thing called a freestyle rap that
has a rap made up on the spot based
entirely on those suggestions it's not
written it's not prepared in advance
I'll never be seen again and do not
worry it won't be anywhere near is
atrociously bad as you are expecting it
to be just so apprehensive all of you
and that's okay should we drop the beat
good sir let's have some fun
[Applause]
[Music]
what either was gonna bump no its gel
we're taking the chill kick it off here
we're taking the chill I'm looking over
on my fields from the top of a hill I
saved my fields technically I don't hold
them we got the king at the top lest he
thrown him underneath this the Knights
in the parents Pro need to work out get
a spade get a hole with e on the end I
don't mean a prostitute I try and chop
it up rotate the crops it's very cute
and make sure that I plant the seed I'm
a serf if you didn't know and now you
grieve them with the lowest of the low
but amid the pyramid working through the
Leeson's a little kid we've gotta give
that to the guy who owns the land and in
England if you don't understand well
this next people get more complex island
is a problem who's next
above them you've got the North
prostitute Catholics yeah par for the
course who was the guy who made that
anger swell probably Oliver Cromwell
back in the day he didn't even like them
that violence he didn't cite them and
they would rise up yes so many and say
bring it down to Londonderry Bloody
Sunday maybe four years ago all the kids
had stones they were gonna throw the
English soldiers over there everybody in
the room this is over your hair you know
studied it not today we don't even know
who the IRA is an island choose to blame
we don't even know Gary Adams or
champagne but that's okay I shoot to
kill I'm gonna get that Hound of the
Baskervilles you might think it's a
ghost think it's a Spectre no it's a dog
with some paint they selector don't kind
of glow in the dark and put it on its
coat it goes over the mall and it goes
and then who's here at that home is
called Sherlock Watson mr. Holt is step
in say I can solve the cases just a dog
you can look it straight in the face and
say stop scaring the people in the
family Arthur Conan Doyle yeah he could
handle bees he moves on it's so cute no
dog I mean being in Beirut a great
holiday that I was on I'm right having
such fun in Lebanon and maybe that was a
will to the head ago a lot of bombs
dropping a lot of bones blow but now
it's a real tourist destination I eat
seafood you can eat crustacean there
yeah it's up in the charts when I'm
feeling free frisky after dark I go out
to the club and here's a fact I like to
go to the script room at the back the
older ladies I'm not scared of them
I'll be specific I like out de Janerio
it means
I will go down there with my mate is we
sit down and we say wow Kings like a
palace who's on the pole a lady called
Gladys walking up yeah we go back to see
the stripper with the press so Sankey
i'm not saying but that's a criticism
I'm saying when I see it I'm spend all
the driz I miss amazing to see her on
the pole - even though those teeth are
no longer dentures I say go on son I
take a little dollar and put it in a gum
not inside accounts
I've never even locket I love that she
wears those high-tops pockets these
banks to hold the wrinkles in probably
long hairs on her chin but that's why I
like I'm not seeing pathetic ordinary
strippers yeah that's my real
[Music]
[Applause]